Steven Shea, Filmmaker: You go through
the entire first level and nothing happens
but the whole time you're waiting for somebody
to jump out of a door at you. Nothing happens.
Then you go to the next level.
It's the same giant hallway
and you start walking by then all of
a sudden you hear a noise behind you.
Film Courage: What has to happen in the
first 10 minutes of a horror screenplay?
Steven: Back in the day they used to say when
they would pick up a horror movie distributors
that you had to have a kill in the
first five minutes of your horror movie.
That was a requirement so most of the time
because you want something to hook the audience
you want to get them in being like this
is what this movie's going to be about
a movie like scream does that really really
well by having this whole like nice happy
seeing and then killing the biggest
actor in the movie which was from psycho
Albert Hitchcock psycho you have a whole opening
sequence with this high-end actress and then they
kill her and then the movie starts and it's
like that's a little more than five minutes
but in screaming was five minutes you need
something big a big inciting incident like
that to hook the audience in and be like
okay this is the ride we're in for and I
think that's important I mean that's important
with every movie you have to have something to
hook them at the beginning to be able to bring
them in and if you start off with a very slow
sequence in the beginning and your audience starts
to nod off 20 minutes in that's a problem you
don't want that to happen so usually try to
start with a bang and end with a bigger bang
I think yeah I know with children of the corn that
was pretty gruesome that was actually too gruesome
for me but with carrie I don't remember within the
first five ten minutes it was kind of a slow build
it is a slow build but it was still very effective
harry is much more like a giallo type style like
an Italian style of a slow lots of reds lots of
deep colors which is a big fan base for for sure
and there's definitely different types of genres
of horror I think that you kind of can look at
I mean there's slasher is a genre and giallo is a
genre there's comedy horror there's action horror
it's really interesting about the comedy horror
is you look back again to the great depression
and comedy horror came in then when they started
introducing Abbot and Costello meets Frankenstein
because the world was on fire and everyone was
depressed so they're like okay we got to bring
movies back in that can raise spirits to kind
of get people's minds off of this they started
introducing those comedy movies with the fans of
of the monsters at the time and so that kind of
helped and that's happened too that happened in
the 80s as well with the horror where it started
off strong strong slashers and then by the end
of the 80s Freddy Krueger is a joke and he's
making one-liners and the movies are funny and
they have like movies like student bodies which
is a spoof of slasher movies then scream ends up
coming out in the 90s which is basically a spoof
of slasher movies as it is just told a little bit
more seriously and then that got its own spoof and
scary movie which they made five of so it kind
of goes in hand hand in hand horror and comedy
but you want that roller coaster you want to
have the tension of of running for your life
and then the humor where it's like oh oh we
survived we're okay he made a joke okay now
I feel better and I'm good and that's like oh oh
oh that's back up and that's back down so that's
the overall hope I guess what about in japan they
had a 10-year depression did what kind of movies
I actually have no idea yeah okay I'm just
curious if it followed a similar and there's
their movies are very spiritual everything's
a spirit a lot of spirit-based demon based
Japanese horror is very specific which is cool
it's very it's very in tuned we went to Japan
for our 10th anniversary and one of the things we
did was we went to this this incredible theme park
called Fuji Q which is the base of mount Fuji
and in it is the world's biggest haunted house
it is four stories tall it's a hospital it's
a massive fully sized hospital and you walk
in and they tell you all your instructions in
Japanese I have no idea what they were saying
and then they're like okay goodbye and they
slam the door and they told us it lasts
45 minutes and I was like how on earth does it
take 45 minutes to walk through a haunted house
and so you go in and it's literally an abandoned
hospital and you go to a hallway there's a room
full of doors and every door is slightly cracked
open there's like 30 doors in front of you and the
lights are flickering but you find out really
quickly something i've never seen before in a
haunted house and one of the this is definitely
the best haunted house experience i've ever had
it's soundproofed so when you get into the
hallway all you hear is your heart beating
you hear nothing it's like a vacuum and you're
like you usually hear that like blast music
and they blast sounds and everything and
there's you're in a line with 100 people
nothing and so all of a sudden they're like okay
go ahead and you have to get out of this hospital
and so you start walking down this long 50-foot
hallway longer than that 100-foot hallway really
and you walk down it you're peeking into each door
and you're like all right my wife's like close and
it's just you and your party so just my wife and
I walking through this entire thing and you walk
around you go through the entire first level
and nothing happens but the whole time you're
waiting for somebody to jump out of a door at you
nothing happens then you go to the next level it's
the same giant hallway and you start walking by
then all of a sudden you hear a noise behind you
and you turn around and you see a guy just
standing in the middle of the hallway staring
at you like zombified just staring and it's just
you too in this big empty hallway and this dude
and then all of a sudden he starts
screaming at the top of his lungs
and he runs at you at full sprint and so of course
my wife is gone like she's taken off and I'm still
looking to see what's going on and so we start you
start running down this hallway and he is right
on your heels like he's screaming at you and you
get to the end of the hallway and you turn around
and he's gone and then you're like we
have 30 more minutes in this building
and you go through all these other little
things and it was crazy but I was like wow
what an experience it was so nuts and i'd
never experienced anything like that before
not in American haunted houses so that
was pretty neat wow that sounds fun and
you can build a lot of creepiness in your own
mind by yourself with nothing around you so
we're kind of subconsciously we're accustomed to
how fear works it's like okay someone's going jump
out of that door or oh this light's going flicker
this thing's going happen that's probably what's
going be people try to walk these haunted houses
and call out everything you go to like Halloween
Horror Nights or something and like well that
guy's going be over there and then he is and
it's like oh but that was a really interesting
experience for sure oh that's really cool I like
that and it's about suspense it sounds like
more than anything oh yeah yeah I mean you
I mean you're of course going you only have one
way to go so you're not really making too many
decisions while you're stuck in this haunted
house but you literally all you hear is your
heart beating because like a vacuum and so
here's like and you've been running around
and so now then you gotta go upstairs and they
have they had certain things that would like
run mechanics so you'd walk by something they
would just go boom and just slam right next to
you and there's nothing there other than a little
mechanical thing and it'd be like oh my gosh
it was awesome that sounds fun I like that
should something scary happen on page one
of a horror screenplay or is it better
to just stretch it out a little farther
I don't think this should happen on page
one I think tension is really important
and I think building in a horror especially you
build your location and you build your characters
and you build your tension I remember there's
a great story about in I'm pretty sure it's the
first alien I can't remember it's alien or aliens
now but there's a whole scene of the spaceship
waking up at the beginning of the movie it's
just the empty hallways and the lights turning on
of the spaceship like introducing this dramatic
arena that we're getting ready to experience
and I always thought that was really important
towards that you you build you want your stories
to build and build and build and so as far as
something scary happening in the very first
page it would have to be like an immediate slam or
something and and I think movies will use gimmicks
like that we're just like boom there's a loud
noise because it's going to startle you because
you're in the theater with bass and surround
sound you're like because it's it's there but
I don't necessarily think it should be on the
first page but by page five you kind of want your
audience to know what they're in for to give them
a little piece of how to expect what's going on
because I like ramping things like starting
off and going up and up and up and you have
little divots and you go up and up and up
and then end so I think that's important too
I also think people are scared by different
things like if you have someone cutting someone's
throat and opening shot someone might be like
someone might be scared by that I wouldn't be
scared by it it's like oh well that sucks for
that person or it's just gross or it's gory
but it's not really scary I feel like the
ultimate fear is is when you feel your
heart start to pound over the tension and the
music and the moments and everything's building
up and something's going happen and you're
baiting the audience to get to a certain point
to then you can slam it in or distract them and
they're kind of like oh that's a good oh and
then it comes out like two seconds later and it
solves them because they're not they're not fully
prepared but every movie is different too it I
think it kind of depends on what what exactly
the script calls for and the vibe the movie has
and kind of what direction you want to go in.